bonjour à tous sur avis de vous
retrouver en direct sur figaro live
merci de nous suivre nous retrouver et
sur lefigaro.fr et sur notre chaîne
youtube ce matin nous avons choisi de
décrypter la nouvelle émission proposée
et présentée par l'animateur cyril
hanouna hier soir à la télévision face à
bah bah c'était son nom était diffusé en
prime sur ces 8 et recevez en premier
invité le candidat nationaliste eric
zemmour nouveau concept d'émission
politique ou énième magazine de
divertissement pimentée par la présence
d'une personne à pau d'une personnalité
politique on débrief avec mon invité ce
matin bonjour damien canivet bonjour
charles marion c'est un plaisir de
province est réciproque merci d'être
avec nous sur le plateau de cigare aux
lèvres les internautes et le public de
figaro live justement mais vous
connaissent bien vous êtes journaliste à
tv mag est d'habitude mais c'est vous
qui posez les questions dans le box tv
mais cette fois ci c'est moi alors le
candidat déclaré eric zemmour a donc
fait face hier un certain nombre
d'opposants politiques et de
personnalités politiques qui se sont
succédé toutes les 10 minutes environ
face à lui d'abord j'ai envie de vous
demander qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de cette émission les
points positifs les points négatifs
qu'est ce qui vous a marqué les coups de
gueule les punchline les fameuses
punchline ou bien on y reviendra
probablement le visage de sarah knafo
conseillère direct éventuellement
qu'elle était très expressif hier soir
c'est vrai on en parlera tout à l'heure
les missions ne se passait pas
simplement sur le plateau ça se passait
également derrière dans les travées du
public écoutez j'ai trouvé que
l'émission était était très sympathique
dans le sens où on a eu un produit
auquel on pouvait s'attendre c'est à
dire une succession de confrontation
face à eric zemmour avec un candidat
très éloquent qui a l'art de la
punchline qui sait répondre à des
détracteurs donc de ce point de vue là
on a eu quelque chose on va dire de pas
très surprenant après moi ce qui m'a un
peu plus surpris en revanche c'est que
je m'attendais à une émission de un peu
plus ancré divertissement c'est à dire
qu'on a un animateur qui s'appelle cyril
hanouna qui est connu effectivement pour
avoir un ton plus ou moins légers et là
hier j'avais le sentiment qui s'était
plus ou moins transformés en interviewer
politique dans le sens où le ton léger
qui peut arborer parfois dans balances
ton poste ou dans touche pas à mon poste
est bien là il avait un peu mis de côté
au profit d'un sérieux peut-être un peu
caricatural parfois il faut reconnaître
il a essayé d'endosser un costume
d'interviewer politique était peut-être
un peu trop grand pour lui
après on a quand même retrouvé voilà des
petites saillies dont lui seul a la
recette c'est à dire quand par exemple
eric zemmour je crois fait tomber son
micro ou voilà il va il va lancer une
petite blague quand il va notamment
citer une marque de fast food à savoir
mcdonald's est derrière pour éviter de
se faire taper par le sénat il va
regarder les téléspectateurs dans les
yeux en disant oh le bon écoutez on va
devoir citer burger king est et quick
tout ça c'est assez drôle et c'est parce
qu'on a l'habitude de voir dans une
émission politique donc il ya eu quand
même un petit peu la patte cyril hanouna
mais à titre personnel j'aurais aimé la
voir davantage vous auriez aimé avoir
d'avantagé ce que ça veut dire que
finalement alors qu'on attendait que les
codes soit cassée que d'ailleurs la
communication de ses vitres rapport à
cette émission annoncée qui on allait
casser les codes la série code ont été
cassées parole sincèrement je ne pense
pas parce que une fois de plus une série
de confrontations et d'altercations en
plateau c'est ce qu'on a l'habitude de
voir sur toutes les chaînes
d'information en continu actuellement
quand vous connecter sur bfm tv à chaque
heure de la journée vous avez par
exemple encore plus sur ces news
d'ailleurs vous avez des débats en
plateau avec des contradicteurs des gens
qui sont vraiment opposés sur
l'échiquier politique et c'est un peu ce
qu'on a eue hier avec quelques petites
surprises notamment eric naulleau par
exemple qui entretient un lien d'amitié
avec eric zemmour et qui n a pas été
vraiment son contradicteur hier soir pas
du tout le même plaisir voilà charlotte
tomber les insa a été reproché un
certain nombre d'internautes hier qui
suivait assidûment ces échanges sur ses
8 et qui ont dit effectivement que la
connivence vraiment flagrante et
l'amitié d'eric naulleau et eric zemmour
était trop flagrante hier ils
n'apportent rien au débat même si je
trouve que c'était intéressant d'avoir
aussi cette confrontation là parce que
on reproche souvent à eric naulleau
d'avancer masqué d'être en fait
quelqu'un qui a des opinions à droite
alors que lui se revendiquent de gauche
et hier il a quand même mis bien en
exergue les points de désaccord qui
l'opposait à eric zemmour sur notamment
l'immigration sur le pouvoir d'achat
donc c'était intéressant de ce point de
vue là mais après c'est vrai que bon
l'amitié étant ce qu'elle est il n'y a
pas eu vraiment de clash oui si j'ose
dire même chose avec charlotte d'enel
haski et le journaliste avait l'heure
actuelle on connaît le positionnement de
ce magazine qui est plus effectivement
pro eric zemmour quand y est voilà lors
de cette séquence là on n'a pas eu
vraiment de débat si j'ose dire musclé
comme ça a pu être le cas avec alexis
corbière alors ces retours vos
rendez-vous et évidemment très attendu
niveau audience est ce que l'émission a
séduit les téléspectateurs étaient au
rendez vous hier ça a cartonné 2,2
millions de téléspectateurs en moyenne
sur la première partie de soirée c'est à
dire de 21h15 à 22h40 soit 10 5% de part
d'audience et un score considérable
savoir que d'habitude les chaînes de la
tnt arrive systématiquement on va dire à
90% des cas derrière les grandes chaînes
hertziennes comme france 2 france 3 et
c'est là à titre de comparaison ces 8es
devant envoyé spécial qui était diffusé
hier sur france 2 ce qui est quand même
une grosse performance pour ses huîtres
une chaîne de la tnt cela s'explique
pour de multiples raisons parce que eric
zemmour est quelqu'un qui de toute façon
lorsque vous l'avez sur un plateau de
télévision va faire de l'audience voilà
c'est quelqu'un dont la parole est très
très écouté il a l'art de la punchline
il est très difficile à bousculer dans
des débats donc on a envie de savoir
s'il y a quelqu'un qui va être capable
de faire tomber eric zemmour après il ya
aussi une autre raison qui je dirais un
peu plus structurelle dans l'émission
c'est à dire que de 21h15 à 22h40 c'est
à dire le moment où l'audience a été
comptabilisé celle dont je vous parlais
de millions de téléspectateurs à ce
moment là y'a 2 millions virgule de 21
ans voient leur divine millions 70
exactement 2,2 millions on va rebondir à
ces moments là entre 21h15 et 22h40 il
n'y a pas de coupure publicité et quand
vous n'avez pas de coupure publicité
bien vous garder le public et lorsqu'on
le regarde la courbe c'est
l'encéphalogramme mais qui est vraiment
droit quoi c'est à dire qu'en fait le
parc les gens sont partis les gens ne
sont pas parties la première coupure pub
en fait elle arrive lors de la deuxième
partie de soirée ça s'appelait face à
bah bah ça continue à ce moment là donc
c'est une autre émission a
officiellement même si c'est exactement
la même un meilleur téléspectateur ne
s'en sont pas rendu compte et bien là on
voit qu'à partir de cette coupure pub là
il ya déjà un petit décrochage de
certains téléspectateurs attend l allure
et écourte la coupure était couru après
sachez que de 22h44 à 00h40 ça s'est
fini extrêmement tard à ce moment là
vous avez 1,6 million de téléspectateurs
quand même qu'ils restent ceux devant
ces 8 15 9% de part d'audience c'est
énorme quand il faut regarder la part
d'audience à ce moment là parce que je
trouve qu'elle est plus révélatrice que
le nombre de téléspectateurs parce que
admettons vous avez je sais pas
dix personnes devant la télévision vous
en avez cinq qui sont sur ces 8 vous
avez 50 % de part d'audience et bien là
sur le total téléspectateurs vous aviez
15 % du public 15 9% du public donc
presque 16 qui était devancé 8 c'est un
score considérable alors l'émission
était en direct contrairement à ce qu'a
fait emmanuel macron quelques jours
précédemment et d'ailleurs ces relevés
par un internaute sur lefigaro.fr qui
nous dit au moins zemmour fait du direct
pas comme macron effectivement sur cet
aspect direct à aucun moment vous avez
eu écho vous que zemmour ou des
intervenants en participant à l'émission
même cyril hanouna lui même aurait pu
émettre un bémol sur le fait de diffuser
en direct ce type de nouveaux projets
cyril hanouna c'est vraiment un amoureux
du direct c'est à dire que ces huit il
faut savoir que c'est l'héritière de
direct 8 une est une chaîne qui étaient
systématiquement en direct sur ces huit
ont fait du direct sur les émissions de
cyril hanouna ont fait du direct et
c'est ce qui plaît aux téléspectateurs
parce qu'on sait que tout peut se passer
quand on est en direct et avec eric
zemmour d'autant plus c'est encore plus
attendu parce que on se dit que tout
peut se passer aussi avec lui on veut
pas se dire que c'est enregistrait qui
pourrait y avoir peut-être une pointe de
montage parce que on sait l'enjeu de
toutes ces émissions vous avez derrière
avoir des communicants politiques vont
aller voir des équipes de production en
coulisses et qu'ils vont dire non mais
là il a peut-être un peu dérapé ça nous
dessert est ce que vous pouvez couper à
ce moment là et puis nous on fera une
concession sur autre chose mais il peut
y avoir ce genre de tractations qui se
passe en coulisses lorsque vous êtes en
direct et vous êtes bien placé pour le
savoir puisque ici sur figaro live nous
le sommes en direct on peut pas faire de
coupure c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de
tricherie et saissac attendent les
téléspectateurs oui ça favorise et
dérapages également exactement et bon
voilà alors après là dessus c'est vrai
qu'ils les membres derrière bien soit là
tous les producteurs avancent aussi à
visage masqué sur cette question c'est à
dire que l'on sait que lorsque vous
faites venir alexis corbière par exemple
député la france insoumise face à eric
zemmour qui est un candidat conservateur
vous savez très bien ce que vous avez un
quart et cinq ans c'était mouvementé
hier forcément au même titre que lorsque
vous avez geoffroy le jeune patron de
valeurs actuelles d'emballant son poste
face à rokhaya diallo qui est plutôt à
gauche sur l'échiquier politique
féministe antiraciste vous savez très
bien que derrière vous allez avoir des
étincelles lors des débats il ne peut
pas en être autrement c'est ce qui a été
aussi un petit peu chercher l'or lors de
cette émission et ça s'est produit les
passes d'armes entre un bixi corbières
et moore était incroyable hier lorsque
alexis corbière aussi discute avec ce
jeune de génération z oui c'est alice la
cegos et président de genii z qu'il a
invectivé alors même qu'ils n'étaient
pas il était dans le public alexis
corbière il a interrompu et les échanges
entre alexis entre stanislas rigaud et
eric zemmour vous pouvez regarder
certainement le replay cette émission
j'imagine si vous avez loupé c'est ces
moments polémique et ses séquences
mouvementée pourquoi cyril hanouna s'est
il engagé dans un tel projet alors pour
quoi sert il à nous la fait de la
politique maintenant parce que je pense
que cyril hanouna commence un peu à
prendre de l'âge et à un moment donné on
peut pas faire le trublion toute sa vie
à la télévision c'est possible mais je
pense aussi que c'est une nouvelle c'est
quelqu'un qui atteint qui écoutent
vraiment aussi le public qui s'ancre
dans une époque mais il sent aujourd'hui
que l'air est au débat un peu plus
sérieux qu'est la galéjade à laquelle il
a pu se prêter par le passé on a aimé
lui coller cette image d'animateur qui
mettait des nouilles dans le slip
souvenez-vous aujourd'hui cyril hanouna
force est de reconnaître qu'il a modifié
son image aujourd'hui les ministres se
pressent en déplaise à certains sur le
plateau de touche pas à mon poste il a
reçu souvenez-vous en 2019 c'était le 25
janvier marlène schiappa à l'époque
c'est la première phase de l'une des
premières fois où il recevait un grand
responsable politique en l'occurrence à
l'époque cette femme était chargé
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes ça avait
fait bondir tous les observateurs
politiques en tout cas la grande
majorité même les responsables
politiques disaient mais attendez une
ministre chez nous là c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de débat
compte c'est à dire que vous avez hier
par exemple elisabeth moreno qui occupe
ce qu'ils gardent ministre délégué
auprès du ministre chargé de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes de la
diversité et de l'égalité des chances
voilà lorsqu'elle arrive sur le plateau
hier à ma connaissance il n'y a pas eu
de député ou que ce soit qui se sont
insurgés parce que cette femme était sur
le yacht aux mains c'est devenu commun
et c'est même un passage obligé pour
certains politiques désormais de
s'étaler dans ses tripes tmx et vous
savez pourquoi parce que il ya une étude
qui a été publiée par nos confrères du
point en mai dernier une étude ifop qui
montre que
dix millions de français majeurs soit un
français sur cinq regarde au moins une
fois par semaine touche pas à mon poste
vous rendez compte 10 millions ça veut
dire que il ya en gros 10 millions de
paires d'oreilles et qui sont
susceptibles d' écouter cette parole
politique là où on se rend compte de
quoi c'est que le public de touche pas à
mon poste en fait c'est un public de
moins de 50 ans ouvrier un petit peu
désenchantée de la politique
généralement ils votent rassemblement
national pour la pour c'est vraiment le
vote qui arrive en premier ensuite c'est
jean luc mélenchon donc en fait il ya
tout un panel des lecteurs ici qu'il
faut convaincre que des candidats ont
envie de convaincre et c'est la raison
pour laquelle en fait les les politiques
se presse chez cyril hanouna il ya un
vrai enjeu et il a ce pouvoir cyril
hanouna de parler à un public qui est
assez large et qui n'est pas forcément
le même que celui sur bfm tv en tout cas
qu'ils n'aiment pas forcément fin qu'il
n'y a pas une appétence politique aussi
impressionnante que sur bfm tv pourrait
se demander malgré tout si ce nouveau
magazine est une création imposé initiée
par la chaîne ou si c'est vraiment une
proposition de cyril da luz cyril
hanouna lui même je pense que c'est cédé
2 c'est à dire que ces huit aussi veut 3
guillemets redorer le blason même si bon
voilà l'image de la chaîne n'était pas
non plus catastrophique mais en vous
proposant ce genre de format avec eric
zemmour qui est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle avec des candidats avec
des personnalités politiques qui vont
sur cette chaîne eh bien ces huit
montrent que c'est une chaîne sérieuse
que c'est une chaîne qui est capable de
peser dans le débat politique et cyril
hanouna aussi n'est pas contre parce que
comme je disais tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui cyril hanouna il a plus
cette image d'entertainer un petit peu
j'ai envie de dire grivois oui voilà
aujourd'hui cyril hanouna mais ça veut
dire qu'ils cherchent à gagner en
crédibilité en sérieux alors on imagine
que derrière tout ça il ya une ambition
à long terme est ce qu'ils cherchent à
avoir un parcours un peu à la marc
olivier fogiel qui partit du
divertissement est aujourd'hui un grand
responsable de chaîne ouais il s'en
cache pas il a commencé sur comédie
souvenez-vous pas très habillée cyril
hanouna il a poursuivi sa carrière avec
des tartes à la crème j'ai envie de vous
dire sur ces 8 et je pense que dans un
avenir plus ou moins proche il
continuera sa voie professionnelle
à la direction d'une chaîne il le dit il
a envie de devenir patron de chaîne il
sera pas d'animateur toute sa vie
l'antenne c'est quelque chose qui le
galvanise c'est quelque chose qui lui
plaît en plus ça fonctionne il suffit de
regarder les audiences donc je pense que
tant que ça fonctionne cyril hanouna
restera l'animateur qui l'est restera à
l'antenne mais au moment où à un moment
donné s'il sent que ça commence à
tanguer que il arrive peut-être plus à
se renouveler eh bien il basculera je
pense dans l'ombre du côté de la
production du côté de la direction enfin
delà du côté de la direction d'une
chaîne c'est ce qu'il a toujours dit de
toute façon alors après ils annoncent
parfois des des dates d'ici cinq ans
d'ici on verra plus mon village a lancé
derrière en réalité tous ceux qui ont
dit ça à un moment donné on leur a
reproché d'avoir donné une échéance
parce qu'ils n'ont jamais vraiment tenu
cyril hanouna peut-être pas encore de
l'antenne jusque 60 ans mais à un moment
donné il va la quitter et je suis
certain qu'il arrivera à la direction
d'une chaîne même si bon c'est entre
nous que cyril hanouna sur ces 8 c'est
un peu lui le patron aussi pensez vous
qu'il a qu'il a joué cette carte dès
qu'il a réussi à jouer cette carte de la
sobriété vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure on l'a vu très en retrait très
sobre dans sa façon de prendre la parole
parfois même un peu maladroit on la sent
tenu qu on l'a senti contenu même dans
dans le fait qu'il ne pouvait pas
intervenir comme il le faisait
d'habitude est ce que cette cette carte
de la sobriété il a réussi à jouer ouais
il a réussi complètement à la jouer
cette carte de la sobriété peut-être un
peu trop d'ailleurs moi j'aurais aimé
voir à cyril hanouna un peu plus
rock'n'roll qui casse un peu plus les
codes qui va peut être lancer une petite
boutade comme lui à l'habitude de faire
parce qu'il a c'est ça aussi la force de
cyril hanouna c'est cet art de pouvoir
d'étendre un débat lorsque justement
tout le monde se crie dessus il l'a fait
à un certain moment c'est à dire que à
un moment donné il a invité alexis
corbière je crois aller boire une tisane
quelque chose comme ça je vous dis il y
avait cette anecdote avec avec mike
mcdonald 20 voilà il a quand même eu ce
petit ton plaisantin mais j'aurais aimé
le voir davantage dans cet exercice là
parce que sans ce ton là malheureusement
vous assistez à une émission politique
classique et ça a été un peu le cas hier
en fait les émissions de cyril hanouna
en fait on a envie de la regarder non
pas parce que ce sont des concepts
originaux et on a envie de la regarder
parce que c'est une parce que c'est lui
parce que c'est incarné par l'unité hier
mois pourrait tout à fait franche pour
avoir regardé j'ai senti qu'il n'était
pas très à l'aise dans ce récit tu
existes cet exercice là pardon est ce
que vous savez s'il a été coaché
justement pour être en deçà de ce qu'il
est d'habitude pour paraître plus sobre
justement je pense pas qu il a été coach
et il ya des équipes qui l'entourent
merveilleusement bien à qui lui font des
fiches voilà qui programment aussi les
invités qui lui que voilà qu'il oriente
mais disons que il a pas il a pas
vraiment de coach en réalité comme vous
avez pu le constater hier vous l'avez
peut-être senti mal à l'aise à certains
besoins humains parce que il n'a pas
forcément les clés non plus selon moi
pour par exemple contester un chiffre
qui va être avancée en plateau comme
peuvent le faire les es salaam et une
est à saluer mais pardon et un laurent
guimier sur france 2 dans une émission
politique il n'ya pas ce background
politique cyril hanouna n'est pas un
journaliste politique c'est un animateur
donc lui hier il a merveilleusement bien
tenu son rôle d'arbitré c'est à dire que
dès lors que ça devenait inaudible dans
l'oreillette on devait lui dire bon on
n'entend plus rien donc il a
intervenants plateau pour dire écoutez
essayez de vous écouter les uns les
autres parfois il relancé aussi eric
zemmour par exemple en lui demandant
vous avez dit ça en telle année est ce
que vous confirmez ce genre de choses
mais c'est vrai qu'il va pas être un
vrai contradicteur vis-à-vis d'une
personnalité politique et j'ai envie de
dire pourquoi pas parce que on a trop
l'habitude aujourd'hui à la télévision
notamment lorsque vous regardez pour
être assez caricatural dans mon exemple
jean jacques bourdin qui a tendance à
mener un vrai combat de boxe lors de ses
interviews c'est à dire à l'américaine
les confrontations voilà c'est il va
effectivement essayé pas de piéger mais
de pousser vraiment l'invité dans ses
retranchements jusqu'au bout avec eric
zemmour avec pardon cyril hanouna il
arrive à rendre sans rendre l'invité
sympathique qu'il arrive à donner un ton
assez bienveillant et je trouve que le
challenge et ça l'a brutalement mais je
trouve que c est anticonformiste
aujourd'hui dans le paysage audiovisuel
d'avoir 7 7
cette capacité a interviewé une
personnalité politique qui l'a tout en
étant sympathique si je désire tout en
l'air en gardant le sourire en étant
bienveillant reyer eric zemmour vous
savez comme moi qu'eric zemmour
lorsqu'il arrive sur un plateau de
télévision notamment sur certaines
chaînes sur france 2 par exemple
certains journalistes se disent bon eric
zemmour on va se le faire on va se faire
parce que il dit des contrevérités parce
que ces chiffres ne sont pas bons on va
essayer de vraiment d'organiser une
vraie confrontation au plateau cyril
hanouna il n'était pas dans cette
optique là il y avait ses invités ses
chroniqueurs pour faire ce job là lui il
était plutôt dans on va remettre les
vérités à plat est ce que ça vous l'avez
vraiment dit ouais mais vous regrettez
pas c'était des c'était plutôt
bienveillant j'ai trouvé et il n'a pas
forcément réduire examu sympathique pour
autant vous connaissez l'animateur vous
avez travaillé avec lui c'est un
exercice donc qui est nouveau pour lui
on vient de le voir dans quel état
d'esprit at il relevé ce défi est ce
qu'il était totalement serein ou bien
quand même un peu affolés moi je pense
que cyril hanouna je le veux comme vous
l'avez souligné j'ai travaillé avec lui
je le connais bien parce que j'ai pu le
rencontrer de discuter avec lui je les
ai vus en coulisses j'ai dû travailler
j'ai vu comment il prépare ses émissions
cyril hanouna cinq minutes avant que les
caméras s'allume même sur ce genre
d'émission il en train de rigoler et de
faire le pitre donc sincèrement je ne
connais pas cyril hanouna folle et je
les ai jamais vus affolé alors c'est un
gros bosseur oui c'est à dire que les
messieurs il a préparé avec ses équipes
je sais de source sûre pour avoir pas
plus tard qu'hier soir dîner avec l'un
de ses proches collaborateurs que il a
bossé jusqu'au bout cette émission mais
vraiment jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la
dernière minute quitte à bousculer le
conducteur mais voilà c'est ça cyril
hanouna c'est à dire qu' il veut le
meilleur et en même temps il n'est pas
spécialement stressé pourquoi parce
qu'il sait que derrière il ya des
équipes qui bossent lui il sait aussi
que il va tenir la barque
je sais que ta mère la barre qu'il n'a
pas pu penser à un moment donné que la
marche était trop haute pour lui non et
puis quand vous savez quand vous avez
alors je n'ai pas compté le nombre
d'intervenants hier mais vous avez vu
que les confrontations une bonne visait
nommément
une dizaine dont quand vous avez dix
personnes qui se succèdent face à cyril
hanouna à lui en l'occurrence c'est ce
qu'il a fait et c'est peut-être ce que
je reproche aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
s'est mis en retrait mais peut-être un
peu trop on avait oublié peut-être un
moment donné que cette émission est
animée par cyril hanouna on aurait voulu
voir mulhouse de cyril hanouna quand
vous regardez pour faire le parallèle
une ambition intimes par exemple avec
karine le marchand sur la malchance
voilà là il ya une vraie identité il
devrait pas quelque chose d'assez
subversif dans le paysage audiovisuel on
n'a pas l'habitude de voir un candidat à
la présidentielle assis sur un canapé en
train de discuter avec une animatrice
qui habituellement à nîmes l'amour est
dans le pré vous voyez sur des questions
bien plus personnel layar j'ai été un
petit peu déçue par le manque
d'originalité je n'ose avouer mais mais
voilà après cyril hanouna il est comme
ça il n'était pas spécialement affolé il
s'est mis un peu en retrait au cir
revenons à l'émission face à baba
effectivement sur le principe de cette
émission et sur les interventions des
uns et des autres face à eric zemmour
qu'est ce que justement à penser eric
zemmour de son passage dans l'émission
on se souvient qu'il n'a pas
particulièrement apprécié son passage
c'est chez tf1 et et notre confrère
gilles bouleau qui l'a traité de connard
m'en sortir de la mission vous avez vous
eu des échos sur ce qu'avait pu penser
eric zemmour de sa prestation et de ce
qui s'est passé pour lui pendant
qu'après deux ou trois heures alors non
je n'ai pas eu d'écho sur le ressenti
d'eric zemmour juste après l'émission ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que quand on
vous offre une tribune en première
partie de soirée de 21h15 jusqu'à minuit
40 c'est difficilement critiquable voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est à dire que là
vous êtes sur une chaîne quand même là
huit ans qui est assez facilement
trouvable sur sur la tnt donc très
regardé la preuve avec l'audience 2,2
millions de téléspectateurs
quand on vous offre une tribune comme ça
avec voilà c'était pas non plus hier une
zone de guerre verbale si j'ose dire oui
c'est à dire que c'était plutôt
bienveillant il a il n'arrivait pas à
envoyer ce n'était pas
une émission face à louis edwy plenel et
jean jacques bourdin vous voyez où la
bon vous arrivez sur un terrain où vous
dites il ya des mines partout là il
était face à des contradicteurs qui
connaît plutôt bien alexis corbière il
le connaît très bien il connaît très
bien eric zemmour eric naulleau pardon
tous ceux qui se sont succédé en plateau
il connaît très bien donc il arrive et
on va dire je pense assez détendu eric
zemmour est la différence avec tf1 que
vous avez cités avec notre confrère
gilles bouleau qui l'a interviewé par ce
qu'il a déclaré sa candidature à la
présidentielle c'est que c'est
extrêmement courts et gilles bouleau à
sa décharge il lui a posé des questions
qui lui semblait essentiel et
malheureusement on ne peut pas aller
vraiment dans le fond dans un format
comme le jt vous n'avez que quelques
petites minutes pour essayer de sortir
les propos de la bouche d'un
interlocuteur là il avait vraiment tout
le temps pour s'exprimer donc très
sincèrement et puis vous l'avez vu aussi
en plateau eric zemmour à aucun moment
vous l'avez senti agacé il a même
d'ailleurs rigoles été reprise il était
nerveux justement ça me permet de venir
au fait que sarko info sa conseillère en
arrière-plan derrière certains invités
donc sur les les plans sur les invités
et les intervenants face à eric zemmour
on la voyait parfaitement derrière et
elle coache en direct eric zemmour dont
elle est la compagne il faut le préciser
il ya des moments où on voit très bien
elle dit souris sourit calme-toi du
calme parce qu'effectivement on le voit
il est à une à la jambe qui est agité il
est parfois moins souriant qu'elle le
souhaiterait ça c'était intéressant ça
c'est très drôle et je m'interroge
beaucoup sur sur ces séquences là parce
que est ce qu'elle savait qu'elle était
filmée et j'imagine que oui parce que
faut savoir que sur le plateau de touche
pas à mon poste parce que c'est le
plateau de touche pas à mon poste en il
faut le rappeler pour ceux qui nous
écoutent que en fait cyril hanouna
tournée essentielle toujours sur le même
plateau c'est à dire que si la touche
pas à mon poste sur le plateau que vous
avez vu hier il ya également balances
ton post il ya une émission qui
s'appelait ya quelques temps de ça c'est
que la télé tout est tourné au même
endroit il ya simplement quelques jeux
de lumière et de des éléments de décor
qui change mais on est au c est
exactement au même endroit et vous avez
un écran retour aussi sur ce plateau on
voit qui est filmé les plans etc sarah
knafo savez très bien mon avis qu'elle
était qu'elle était filmée est-ce que
c'était pour montrer aussi on la voyait
on a parfaitement elle était pas dans
l'ombre mais elle avait pas de masque
elle n'avait pas levé alors qu'elle
était dans le public tous les autres
étaient masqués exactement donc il y
avait une volonté à mon sens de montrer
toute l'implication de cette femme dans
la campagne
d'eric zemmour et ça a été parfaitement
en fait c'était très curieux de voir
moment donné même un titre personnel
j'ai écouté même plus le débat je
regardais ce qui se passait derrière je
regardais les mimiques les sourires vous
n'êtes pas le seul à l'avoir fait il ya
beaucoup de capture de ces moments là
qui ont été diffusées sur les réseaux
sociaux etc on peut voir et c'est assez
intéressant à regarder parce que c'est
totalement inhabituel et inédit bien sûr
c'est qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
ce genre de choses alors après il ya des
émissions notamment sur france 2 je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez de cette
émission à l'époque quand il y avait
encore du public parce que avec une
pandémie de kobe de 19 que vous
n'ignorez pas malheureusement de
nombreux plateaux ou renoncer au public
mais lorsqu'il y avait cette émission
politique qui s'appelait des paroles et
des actes souvenez-vous animé par david
pujadas oui vous aviez un invité fil
rouge avec des contradicteurs qui venait
face à cet invité vous aviez toujours
l'équipe de soutien qui se trouvait
derrière cet invité là et là aussi vous
voyez les réactions des uns et des
autres plus récemment encore dans
l'émission politique sur france 2 avant
même la pandémie il y avait encore du
public et vous aviez je crois le premier
ministre qui était invité quelque chose
comme ça et puis derrière vous aviez
tous les ministres qui étaient alignés
et là aussi ça intéresse différence
c'est qu'effectivement il ya un rapport
qui va au delà du professionnel est
vraiment rentrer
sarah knafo il y avait aussi un regard
qui n'était pas la leur qu'ils peuvent
voilà un regard people absolument est-ce
que d'autres politiques pourraient être
séduits par par cet exercice et par le
fait d'être reçu dans cette émission est
ce que cevital a prévu d'autres invités
politiques ou autres alors je peux vous
assurer qu'avec un score comme celui de
2 2 millions de téléspectateurs c'est 8
on a prévu d'autres à mon avis qui vont
arriver très très vite
après ceux sur ce format la face à bah
vous n'allez pas forcément avoir
d'autres invités politiques il a bien
précisé cyril hanouna l'objectif de ce
magazine c'est de recevoir toutes les
personnalités qui sont au centre de
l'actualité eric zemmour en fait partie
puisqu'il annoncé récemment sa
candidature mais à l'avenir il ne
s'empêche pas à pas il ne s'interdit pas
de recevoir des sportifs par exemple il
a notamment cité le nom de killian mba p
il va il aimerait bien recevoir aussi
des artistes issus du monde de la
musique pourquoi pas booba on sait qu'il
est il est très ami avec lui après je
peux d'ores et déjà vous annoncer que
les 2,2 millions de téléspectateurs
vraisemblablement ce sera le record
d'audience de cette émission qui sera
pendant longtemps imbattable parce que
c'était une première il y avait une
vraie attente autour de cette émission
là on a un invité très fort pour
inaugurer ce format là qui s'appelle
eric zemmour lorsque derrière vous allez
recevoir un invité qui certes est au
centre de l'actualité mais qui est un
peu moins prestigieux forcément
l'attendre sera un peu moins importante
ce sera le deuxième numéro et ce sera
compliqué imaginez
ce sens sans aucune animosité valérie
pécresse qui passe juste après ce sera
un peu moins attendue malheureusement
parce que c'est pas la même éloquence
c'est pas la même attente c'est
différent après il faut savoir à
charlotte pour répondre à votre question
que cyril hanouna l'intention aussi de
sart de lancer un autre magazine qui l'a
sera sera plus politique exactement à
100% politique et là vous avez
des biscottes
alors ça s'appellera la façon dont cette
fois ci on pourrait éventuellement avoir
un projet d'émission politique
totalement inédit exactement alors en
fait cédé me sens ça s'appellera c'est à
vous douce et déjà vous de voter ce sera
lancé début 2010 22 et là effectivement
l'objectif premier de cette émission là
ce sera de recevoir tous les candidats
qui sont inscrits dans la course à
l'elysée eric zemmour va revenir du
groupe parce que là c'est vraiment une
émission politique où il a vocation à
recevoir chaque candidat avec le même
temps de parole avec le même format etc
l'associât le rôle jouera cyril hanouna
dans cette affaire alors si vous savez
en fait à h2o productions qui est la
société de production de cyril hanouna
disons que on a les concepts d'émissions
à ses taux ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
et décidé on va dire quelques semaines
avant donc pour l'instant on n'a
absolument aucune idée de ce qui se
passera dans cette émission c'est aussi
une force il tombe il forma ni la durée
ni le format ni la durée sera du prime
time vraisemblablement mai mais on ne
sait pas vraiment les rubriques qui
seront à l'intérieur dites-vous que face
à bubba il ya encore deux semaines de ça
on n'avait jamais une vague idée de ce
qui allait être mis à l'intérieur dans
tv magazine nous avons écrit un article
oui sur sur cette émission il se trouve
que j'avais pour vous dévoiler un peu
les coulisses de cet article un
communiqué de presse face à moi qui
étais assez succinct je vais assez peu
d'éléments pour pouvoir bâtir mon
article j'ai donc appelé un contact au
sein des jo production qui m'a expliqué
un peu les rubriques qui allait y avoir
à l'intérieur il se trouve que ces
rubriques là n'ont pas forcément été
respectée deux semaines plus tard on
avant une émission qui ressemble pas
vraiment à celle que j'avais annoncé
dans l'article voyez il se laisse le
droit de modifier jusqu'à la dernière
minute jusqu'à la dernière minute
jusqu'à la dernière affaire donne un
point là il peut faire écouter le
conducteur qui est le menu de l'émission
jusqu'à la dernière minute il peut quand
vous avez une entrée plat dessert prévue
pour noël lui il peut arriver
cinq minutes avant le repas et qu'il
veut vous servir et l'échangé de tout le
menu ça c'est possible c'est une nana a
l'habitude de faire ça donc voilà dans
cette émission c'est déjà à vous de
voter il va recevoir tous les candidats
c'est à vous de voter il a déjà vous
devez déjà à vous devez exactement et
dans le public il y aura a priori 200
membres qui eux pourront voter et
s'exprimer justement sur la prestation
du candidat qui qui est en plateau il ya
de nombreux commentaires sur les réseaux
sociaux di figaro sur le chat du
figaro.fr il y en a un qui est
intéressant c'est anonyme 28 0 63 qui
nous dit c'est 8 est une alternative à
brut youtube
c'est c'est intéressant c'est
intéressant oui pourquoi parce que le
point commun entre tous ces médias c'est
qu'il parle aux jeunes
voilà c'est vrai que les autres tokyo
cyril hanouna a ce pouvoir effectivement
comme brut comme comme youtube de de
parler aux jeunes de parler un public
qui est peut-être plus jeune que celui
qu'on peut retrouver sur sur france 2
qui est au delà des 60 ans c'est une
annonce un public plutôt en dessous des
50 ans on va dire que ça c'est un vrai
dire que l'âge moyen c'est entre 25 et
49 ans c'est vraiment le coeur de cible
du public de de cyril hanouna et pour
rejoindre la remarque de cet internaute
c'est qu'eux aussi ils sont très
puissants sur le numérique mais aussi
des pmp comme brut qui est très puissant
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux tpm paix
est très commentée récemment twitter a
sorti les dix hashtag les plus commentés
en 2021 tpm paix est le dixième hashtag
le plus utilisé en 2021 vous rendez
compte c'est à dire que une période où
vous avez l'actualité partout eric
zemmour le co lead le vaccin est bien
tpm paix fait encore partie des dix
sujets les plus commentés sur la toile
c'est aussi l'une des raisons d'ailleurs
pour encore donner un élément de plus à
votre question c'est l'une des raisons
aussi pour lesquelles les ministres se
pressent aussi sur le plateau de cyril
hanouna ya cette audience télévisuelle
cette audience dont on a parlé de 2,2
millions de téléspectateurs qui est
considérable mais imaginez l'impact sur
les réseaux sociaux derrière il suffit
que vous alliez sur le compte twitter de
touche pas à mon poste pour vous rendre
compte à quel point toutes les vidéos
qui sont découpées montée elles sont
relayés entre la machine de guerre c'est
une machine de guerre et en plus de ça
toute la presse s'en fait l'écho il
suffit de regarder ce matin tous les
articles qui ont été écrits en lien avec
cette émission il y avait un grand nous
mêmes traitons respectivement et en
débriefant c'est direct n'a pas grand
chose qui s'est passé d'ailleurs c'est
requis la plus grande annonce hier
d'eric zemmour et pourtant malgré tout
ce matin tapée fass ababa sur google
très simple vous allez voir le nombre le
nombre d'articles qui ont été qui ont
été publiés merci à vous anonyme le 28 0
63 qui nous remercient en retour d'avoir
posé cette question au nôtre direct
arrive à toucher à sa fin nous avons
fait une demi heure ensemble pour vous
débriefer donc ce direct ce nouveau
direct ce nouveau magazine présenté et
animé et proposait hier soir par par
cyril hanouna et dans lequel il a reçu
donc le candidat nationaliste eric
zemmour devant et un certain nombre
d'invités politiques et autres à on
pourra les cités on veut juste pour
rappeler parce qu'on l'a pas dit parmi
les invités alors mathieu kassovitz
était attendu il avait été testé positif
au co vite donc il n'a pas fait cet
entretien et ce face à face avec aymeric
caron eric naulleau elisabeth moreno la
ministre alexis corbière stanislas
rigaux christine kelly mathias wargon
charlotte dernier l'as et karim zéribi
et ex député européen voilà c'était la
liste non exhaustive des différentes
personnalités qui se sont opposés à
l'eczéma ou pas d'ailleurs durant ces
trois heures de direct merci beaucoup
d'amants siège chariote j'espère vous
retrouver bientôt c'était un plaisir de
partager ce moment en attendant on
souhaite de bonnes fêtes à ceux qui nous
suivent
vous aurez rendez vous avec fear alive
même pendant les fêtes si l'actualité le
justifie je vous souhaite de bonnes
fêtes joyeux noël et puis à très vite
sur figaro live